one of the most popular super bowl ads
from sunday night was t-mobile's ad
featuring adam levine playing the
fictional matchmaker for blake shelton
and gwen stefani
the commercial is trending at number
four on youtube right now
yeah blake tells entertainment weekly
that he loved poking fun at their
oddball relationship saying
it was funny we had a blast when i read
the script i thought it was a great idea
i thought it was so
funny because people still don't really
understand why she's with me
and fair enough right so i loved being
able to spin that out
here's the ad hey adam
when's stefani what's happening i think
i'm ready to start dating again
what are you looking for i'm sick of la
guys i want someone completely different
maybe from another country and someone
cultured insensitive and who is not
threatened by a strong competent woman
on a spotty network this is what adam
heard
sick of l.a guys i want someone
completely country uncultured
and threatened by a strong confident
woman
it's not wings or nachos it's wings and
nachos
hey send my onion rings down here i have
you guys
quinn blake um oh my god hilarious right
i mean no what do you mean
are you wearing spurs did you ride a
horse here yeah
don't trust your love life to just any
network
okay so obviously the reaction has been
huge for this blake's phone could barely
keep
up on sunday night he tells ew of all
the things i've been fortunate enough to
have happen in my life i don't know my
phone has ever erupted
i mean my phone was smoking last night
you realize oh my god nobody's ever
really watched me win an award
i know that now but everybody watches
the super bowl now it's confirmed
i know every contact in my phone was
watching that game
keisha what did you think of that ad
that will be fun i
think that is hilarious like one could
have easily been like you know
i just want someone that makes me feel
rich on minimum wage she could have
totally played off that
this is great this is great this is
great branding for them
because obviously with that song you
know it's kind of it was a weird energy
i feel like this shifted things
this is hilarious love them
happy
i i like oddball couples and i think
it's i think it's endearing that they
recognize
that it's a little bit oddball and sort
of people kind of tilt their head a
little bit
just because they were so well known
before they hooked up
i think that if they had met in high
school and he just you know turned out
to be this and she turned out to be that
it wouldn't be a thing but it's how did
these two even just like knowing two
famous people
that were that different um or appear to
be that different anyway the aesthetics
are very very different the way they
talk is very different
but i find it incredibly endearing and
i'm a huge fan of these sort of oddball
couples it was like years ago
when uh kate hudson was with chris
robinson from the black crows or
that brief period where sandra bullock
was with jesse james the like the
motorcycle guy
like you just wonder like how did this
even happen and they're they're
fascinating but i
love these two i i really do i think
that you know gwen looks like she's been
having
more fun than she's had in her entire
life and career
and and i think that they bring out the
best in each other and i love that they
they realize that you know people love
to see them just be
you know odd it's great yeah margaret
says that is awesome yeah linda says i
love it that was so good
zoe says blake and gwen are bore af
um bb says why is gwen with blake please
please answer so what do you think the
appeal is i mean yeah it's a funny
commercial it's funny they poke fun each
other
but let's let's analyze keisha why do
you think gwen is with
well here's the thing here's the thing
you know when you're young
in the industry and whatnot you know
you're you know super career focused and
you're probably looking for the
next adrenaline rush in the next thing
um but you get to a point where you're
like i just want
someone that's going to allow me to be
great
that's going to allow me to work hard
and be busy
and to focus on the things that i want
to focus and sometimes it's that someone
who's also like-minded
i think that blake probably grounds her
in a lot of ways um
and i think that he probably feels like
home i think there's something really
interesting i think for blake gwen's
probably really
you know uh interesting probably
exciting
um i see i can see why this works who
wouldn't want
to be in a relationship with someone who
had the same kind of life experiences i
mean they both share the same lifestyles
the same type of careers they were on
the same show continue to be for
years it's like it's kind of a perfect
situation if you ask me a little
odd but it's kind of i like it
it's not it's it's it's not their first
relationships right these this is this
is
the sex sort of second time you know
around for both of them and i think that
you just get to a certain point in your
life
where you just want to laugh and
i get the sense that blake shelton makes
her
laugh and i think that she does the same
for him and then that is how
all of this happens i think it's
probably something as simple as that
yeah now a lot of people are bringing up
miranda moss says i'm sure miranda was
laughing though
paul says poor miranda sing all this
media on the gal who took her man
i think miranda's doing just fine it
does remind me
this does remind me that blake and
miranda did a lot of stuff right in
terms of getting ahead of
tabloid and stuff like that so i feel
like this is kind of blake doing the
same thing of
you know making a joke before you can
make the joke about that
yeah totally i forgot about miranda ooh
let's keep forgetting she's fine yeah
she's fine
yeah randall is doing okay
yeah yeah